[Music]
in 1949 harry s truman was tired world
war ii had just ended and in his second
inaugural address truman needed to
inspire americans weary after years of
war to do it
he painted America and a fresh and
altruistically he said and I quote more
than half the world's population live in
conditions approaching misery their
economic life is primitive and stagnant
we must embark on a bold new program for
the improvement and growth of
underdeveloped areas
what Truman is saying here is a powerful
new idea in the world development if the
West pulls our resources we can help
poor developing countries do just that
develop get richer it's an uplifting
narrative making Americans feel good
that we can help one small issue this
was a total PR play it was a concept
made up ten days prior by a mid-level
State Department employee whose only
mandate was to reignite American energy
for Truman's second term at the time of
the speech not one document existed to
support the actual execution of the plan
and to put this in historical context a
Western led narrative at the time of
benevolence was unprecedented Western
led colonialism was still going on
after World War two at the time of the
speech but Americans loved the new
narrative and we followed through and
today the West mainly US and Europe give
on average a hundred and thirty billion
in aid per year this is through large
philanthropies like the Gates Foundation
through multilaterals like the World
Bank and IMF and through traditional
government aid like USAID or dip it in
the UK and through our collective giving
Truman's narrative has stood the test of
time rich countries help poor countries
it's something we all kind of know but
for this idea to have legs we need to
believe that it's in some way working
that that 130 billion we give in aid per
year is having real impact and the poor
are getting less poor and that too is a
widely touted narrative in 2015 the UN
published a landmark report that said
that the global poverty rate has been
cut in half over the last thirty years
and that sounds great
because that means that our efforts are
working and our global economic system
is sound and we should all feel good
about that if not for a difficult fact
Global Poverty isn't getting better in
fact it hasn't budged in 30 years so the
2015 claim of huge wins against global
poverty relies on an antiquated $2 a day
poverty line that poverty line is set by
the same institutions responsible for
showing progress against poverty and so
that line is abysmal ehlo most
development economists today cite that
it takes closer to an $8 a day poverty
line to achieve basic nutrition and
normal human life expectancy and if we
look at the $8 a day poverty line and
subtract out China which has taken its
own development efforts recently outside
of US control we see that the proportion
of people living in extreme poverty
hasn't meaningfully changed in three
decades and we can see this reflected
again in our ever-growing global
inequality the gap in GDP per capita
between rich and poor countries has
tripled since the time of Truman's
speech let that sink in
this is not a tale of poor countries
catching up to the West this is a story
of a growing poverty divided for me this
is a profound thing to grapple with I
work in development economics and I've
worked to expand access to credit for
the unbanked in emerging markets
I lived between Peru and Indonesia and
Kenya and I thought I was part of a wave
of things generally getting better so
the idea that global poverty is not
getting better
hits me to my core and it forces me to
ask my trillion dollar question in the
face of all of these development efforts
why aren't we making progress against
poverty and in that is the Western
influence I'm a part of helping or
hurting my favorite development
economist Jason Hickel has a shocking
idea what if aid all the bridges all the
bed nets is irrelevant or worse than
irrelevant what if it is nothing more
than a convincing PR play like Truman's
speech a distraction in this narrative
we get to be the good guys the West is
helping the poor catch up and everyone
gets to sleep at night knowing we are
doing what we can and we don't have to
do anything differently besides maybe
give a little bit more an aid per year
if our global economic system is working
to alleviate poverty but clearly it's
not working so what's going on here why
haven't we made progress against poverty
despite half a century of effort I want
to put that 130 billion in aid per year
in perspective that's a big number
but it's much smaller than the value
that flows in the opposite direction
from poor to rich in 2016 the global
financial integrity group published
shocking data on the ways that value is
extracted out of
four countries this is not trade flows
but ways that value is being transferred
sometimes illegally from poor to rich so
when Western governments give loans to
poor countries to the IMF we demand back
substantial interest rate exorbitant
interest rates and with the miracle of
compound interest many poor countries
are continuously crippled under their
debt burden some of these debts were
taken decades ago and the principle has
been long repaid but we keep demanding
back interest to put this debts in
perspective the amount that poor
countries spend on debt service each
year is a bigger number than the UN
projects is needed to eradicate global
poverty completely and when we loan on
top of interest we have structural
adjustment so that's when Western
governments lend to poor countries we
demand the poor countries adopt certain
economic policies and we tell them these
policies will help them develop but
really these are policies of free trade
and low tariffs that benefit our Western
corporations working there and most
nefariously of all we have trade miss
invoicing which is the very illegal yet
very prevalent practice of large
corporations misreporting trade prices
on our invoices in order to avoid local
government taxes there's a lot more ways
that value flows from poor to rich but
the point here is that our aid budget is
ridiculously small compared to all the
ways money is gushing out of poor
countries this is outrageous
especially because we've used our tiny
aid budget to fuel a cultural narrative
of our own benevolence and that
narrative hides the patterns of
extraction that are actively keeping
poor countries poor maybe this isn't all
that surprising given centuries of
Western lead extraction under
colonialism I would argue it's the same
extraction
hidden behind a PR bandaid of
development I work in development so
seeing these numbers is deeply troubling
and to be clear I don't think
development in and of itself is bad but
it shouldn't be used as a cover-up for
extractive global economic system
imposed by the West and I've realized I
need to get my head up out of the sand
and look at this straight on if I want
to do any good and if you want to join
me there's places to start large
companies give lip service to things
like ESG through impact and CSR but I
think we need a new code of ethics so
when you run large corporations in the
developing world do basic things like
pay your fair share of taxes and demand
the companies you work for do too and
for all of us in the broader West I want
to challenge us to rethink our role in
development and stop hiding behind a
narrative that the West is helping to be
really blunt if you're from a rich
country your privilege was built on the
backs of those in poor countries and
continues to be built on them we have to
get our story straight rich countries
aren't developing poor countries it's
the other way around thank you
[Applause]
[Music]